what's a contrarian to you I think I
want to steal a quote for this one which
is Christopher Hitchens and his quote
was a contrarian is not one who always
disagrees but one who questions
everything and so my idea is in the
world that we have right now it's
probably pretty smart to question
assumptions continuously and the humans
who do that are the ones that win over
time uh I don't think the goal is to
just be orinary or to Counter Culture
but to actually use your brain to come
up with a formulation of thoughts that
is unique to you is that not
antithetical to moving quickly if you've
got to question everything super
effortful that means you can't make
decisions quite as fast it's interesting
you say that we were talking about a
mutual friend of ours Bill Perkins and
Bill told me uh he has two superpowers
that have led to every single dollar
he's made and he goes uh it is that I'm
willing to take risk and I move faster
than everybody else so by the time
they've even pondered an idea I've
already done it made five mistakes and
learned Five Lessons and every time I
meet with Bill I realize that's exactly
right and that's why he's one of the
most successful people that I've ever
met and yet I think if you don't
question things and you don't have a
brilliant mind like he seems to you're
just going to be on the wrong road path
and if you don't actually know the goal
that you want to hit if you don't
actually know where you're going most
people move forward towards things that
they actually don't want in life and
I've done it many many times and so in
my mind if you don't question UPF front
then you might not actually like the
answer you get to when you find it yeah
the intentionality point I think is so
important and it comes up in dating it
comes up in business it comes up in
where you're going to live what sort of
Lifestyle you're going to have how much
success do you want o that's a [__]
big one so this really cool quote that I
saw from uh Nassim talb the world is
split between those who don't know how
to start making money and those who
don't know when to stop oh yeah that
hits home huh how you feeling that one
I'm feeling that one that's kind of deep
yeah yeah well I think he's he's right
but thank God there are some humans that
don't stop like sometimes I think about
you couldn't pay me enough money to
switch places with Elon Musk there's not
enough money out there I am so glad that
he exists as a human in the world
because we get to benefit from the
Creations that he makes but I don't
think he looks very happy and sometimes
the person that I actually you know lust
after from an exchange of Life
perspective is the person who owns a
couple of cash flowing businesses
happily married couple of kids in good
shape has tons of free time and is
really close to their community and uh
it's not the person who has built
multiple billions of dollars because at
the end of the day what are you going to
do with it and so unfortunately I'm
wired as one of those freakish humans
that loves the game does not know when
to stop and finds everything else pales
by nature but I do think he's he's right
don't you yeah I the idea of when is
enough enough is such an interesting
question and you've heard the parable of
the Mexican fisherman oh such a good one
yeah so for the people that don't know
this sort of very interesting Parable
that shows there is a quicker shortcut
to the life that you want by reducing
down complexity not overcooking how much
you achieve and then just going for
Simplicity in the first place right
rather than having to build an elaborate
life to then eventually be able to
afford a simple one like the elaborate
life is kind of unnecessary once
especially once you cross a certain
threshold of of income and wealth
another cool quote about contrarianism a
contrarian isn't one who always objects
that's a conformist of a different sort
a contrarian reasons independently from
the ground up and resists pressure to
conform hitet right Naval oh that was
Naval good one okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's nval I love the fact that when
we're thinking about pushing back
against
Conformity like the average American is
obese Divorced with less than onek in
the bank right yep taking the normal
route might feel safe in the moment but
it's actually a really undesirable thing
to do because you can see the the
outcomes that you're going to get
they're there in front of you yeah I
mean I was reading statistics the other
week about the if there's one out of 10
uh Americans that get to age 65 by that
point only one of them will be
independently wealthy uh and by the time
they die uh only one of them will be
independently wealthy we will have uh I
think it's two people will have actually
died by the time they go to retire so
they won't even have made it there um
the other two will actually be on
government welfare or uh someone else's
dime AK their family Etc and so what we
have done systematically is not working
if only 10% of the population actually
dies with excess cash um because
funerals are expensive and so I think
you know was interesting what I really
respected about Naval in many different
ways but I remember when he was first
building
angelist um I interacted with him a few
times on Twitter we're by no means
friends but we interacted a few times
after it had done you know been valued
at a few billion dollars and uh and I
was bothering him and his team I'm like
I buy businesses all day long there's
nothing like angelist for people who
actually buy companies and want to own
total majority majority shares as
opposed to just small segments of
companies like VC you guys have all the
capability just build it and I remember
I was kind of getting through to his I
don't know if it was a CEO or a COO at
the time and then Nal just came in was
like it is not what we do we do and we
are the best in the world at serving
Venture Capital style businesses and
small minority shares and he's like if
we wanted to be everything to everybody
we would have never hit our first
billion and I was like all right sir you
know and I tot I get his point um but to
stand up when you have that much
capacity and capital and see so many
shiny objects everywhere and continue to
say no to the ones that don't serve you
is a real superpower too well don't
forget that that is another type of
non-conform ity right that is another
type of contrarianism to not say yes to
everything and it's I've been thinking
about this so much the tools that you
need when you begin a pursuit or when
you begin a journey are sometimes even
the opposite ones that you need as you
begin to develop so uh let's say that
it's growing a business in the beginning
you need to be very detail oriented you
need to be across everything you need to
be completely obsessive about all of
this stuff that's going on and then
after a while you actually need to be
able to learn to delegate and the skill
which made you effective in the
beginning and you have proof is good and
you get dopamine from doing and you're
habituated to continuing to do it is
exactly the one that's going to hold you
back if you can't let go later on uh if
we were to talk about um status and the
things that come to you explore in the
beginning try lots of different things
make as many connections as you can
finally build up some sort of a
reputation and then as the reputation
Rises and Rises and Rises you actually
need to no longer say yes to everything
you need to say no to almost everything
right so it again the skill that you
develop in the beginning is often not
the thing that is useful at the end and
you've you're so inculcated into this
rhythm of doing it and you're I'm trying
to cast off this habit of me doing that
thing it's very difficult oh yeah well
especially if you think about uh dollar
amounts so when you first make your
first $100,000 there's a skill set that
I think is quite normalized if you want
to make $100,000 which is you need to
learn as much as possible in order to
increase your earnings predominantly
working for somebody is the fastest way
to get to your first 100K and that same
skill set to get from 100K to a million
is relatively similar so you can get to
a million dollars pretty much using that
same skill set but in order for you to
become an employee that has a high level
of learning and a high level of earning
that is worth $10 million actually quite
hard the difference between a million
and 10 million is difficult and to go
from 10 to 100 million is categorically
different and to go from 100 million to
a billion if you just look at the math
between the two uh there is no possible
way for you to do it it as an employee
like it hasn't been done there is not a
billionaire that was an employee of
somebody else's company and so the the
math just doesn't lie and so because of
that I think it's really interesting to
determine what is what is it that you
actually want who has achieved it before
what are the characteristics that are
similar uh in those subset of humans
that have done it and then can you
actually find a road map or Ripple or
rhyme between all of those humans to get
to the next level and it's a it's a
superpower to be able to see through the
mat tricks like that to figure out the
difference between 1 and 10 and 100 and
a billion yeah what's your uh how do you
ensure that you're remaining intentional
like what's your framework for
non-conformity a couple different things
the the first thing that this is a
friend of mine Alex and I um he's I sit
on the board of his hedge fund he's one
of the smartest men I know and he runs a
a multi-billion dollar hedge fund
portfolio and I remember you know we
focus a lot on this idea of how do we
think different differently than other
people because if you invest just like
everybody else as an investor on average
you lose money over time to inflation
that is just the truth most humans
without a financial adviser in the
market actually lose money over time in
the stock market and what people say
instead is no the stock market returns
10% a year on average yes the stock
market as an entity that is not you
individually you individually lose money
over time in the stock market which is
wild and so when I started thinking
about it as a numbers game with him I
realize the funnel to non-conformity is
essentially this it is you have to
continue to question the thoughts that
you have inherently you have to uh be
off from everybody else slightly and you
have to figure out how to be right those
two things are really really hard to be
consistently have a different
perspective and be right on those
perspectives and that's the only way you
can actually make money long term in the
stock market or really in just about
anything where you want to be worth over
$100 million you can definitely be in
consensus and make a million 2 million
10 million maybe even 25 or
50 it's interesting to think
about the the fact that you can't signal
off what everybody else is doing if you
want to get outsides results right
ultimately if you do end up signaling
off everyone else you're going to end up
with results that are at least
comparable with what they're doing and I
suppose that this kind of at least in
part relates to you are the average of
the five people that you spend the most
time with I actually think that there's
a better rule which is you are the
average of the five podcasts you listen
to the most um can't imagine why I think
my ego knows no bounds um but the
outsized influence of the people that
you're around ultimately you're still
going to inhabit encounter the same
problem unless you and everybody else
that your friends with is on this insane
growth trajectory so all right so what's
going to happen you you somehow when you
are at this stage of your personal
growth family growth wealth growth
Journey going to find for other people
all of whom are going to have the exact
same trajectory that you do and I think
this is why there's definitely a degree
of loneliness that I have seen to a lot
of people who achieve rapid success
because it's very hard to find some
people to come with you on that Journey
because your growth is
so rapidly accelerating like who what's
the chance that you find somebody else
that's able to come along with you or
maybe the person that you're with is
moving quicker than you are so I think
what seems to happen is people kind of
move through bubbles of friends so as
they're going on their Journey okay I'm
in this new bracket and then that kind
of falls behind and then I'm in a new
bracket and then that kind of falls
behind at least I see that through Alex
as a good example yeah no I think that's
exactly right I mean the sad thing is
and youi and Alex have talked about this
before I think and he might have even
been the one that said it which was
other people want you to be just
slightly less successful than they are
on average and um and I think that is a
grow gross generalization in that not
everybody's like that but a
preponderance of humans because we're
scarcity mindset it's how we were wired
um you know from learning how to survive
on the planes uh we know that if there's
a bunch of other people around us
historically there weren't enough
resources to go around you know we had
to actually be protective of the things
that we made now in today's world in
which innovation continues to allow us
to achieve more and more and there's
actually it doesn't have to a zero sum
game I don't think we have caught up
here with what we know out here in the
Innovation sphere that's interesting so
if you say uh if you're the smartest
person in the room you're in the wrong
room but what it's also doing that sort
of a rule is protecting you from being
the person that's going to receive the A
and the jealousy and the backbiting from
the other people so endeavoring to be
the poorest person in the room or the
most stupid person in the room or the
least accomplished person in the room
ensures that you're going to receive
less and less and less Envy or or or
that's actually really true I mean we
were thinking about it the other day and
I was trying to imagine a person who is
really really successful monetarily if
we want to say who um actively trolls
people and uh and is negative to others
and I can think of a few right you could
think of like Elon Musk does some
trolling on the internet the Paul
Brothers do but why do they do that they
do that because it's actually a direct
Revenue line to a thing that they care
about right
exact we are we want to have this atten
ARR trade so because of that we are
willing to tr but for the Aver
successful person I have never met a
successful human that doesn't have a
monetary incentive to troll the trolls
they just don't exist like if you want
to figure out if somebody is going to be
successful or not I think you should go
and look in their Twitter replies and
comments and if they have a bunch of
negative ones you go not hiring them and
also not investing in them because that
type of human all they can do is they
can take rocks and and they can throw
them because they don't realize they
should build with them and so it's it's
one of the biggest signals in our
companies actually we have a social
media screen so for every single hire
that we have across our companies we see
do you have a negative perspective on
reality and do you play the victim
frequently and if you are either of
those two things you're just not part of
our ecosystem we do not believe that
humans like you will be successful with
an attitude like that wow okay you've
got a lesson the controversy and
Conformity conundrum there is a spectrum
where controversies and conformity sit
on two ends of the line more Conformity
equals less controversial and yet most
of the winds in life land on the edge of
controversy choose your controversy
wisely but choose it yeah well I think
you can play this out most easily on
social media right it's just very easy
to tell uh once you have an eye towards
Frameworks is this tweet going to do
well is this tweet not going to do well
depending on is it something that is
slightly off from the norm and my Angela
said you know people aren't going to
remember what you said but they will
remember the way you made them feel and
that was this touchy feely thing that
she said that I never really associated
with until I saw Twitter and I said that
is exactly right the second that you can
make somebody feel something on one way
or the other they are going to react to
it and often we humans react really
aggressively without thinking about it
at all in fact I found myself doing it
now I I sort of have to train myself not
but when I see something on the Internet
you know there's like that famous Tom
Hardy little meme where is like that's
clickbait have you ever seen that I know
what that is that's bait right and now
we can tell why because if it's slightly
off from the norm it is going to attract
our attention because just like if there
was where's Waldo and red and white
stripes in a sea of people in green
you're going to note this thing that
looks slightly differently and I was
talking to a room yesterday of a bunch
of uh Builders and some of our our
companies and um they were asking me how
do you how do you build a personal brand
and how do you tweet and know what
what's going to work one way or the
other and uh I don't know if I've ever
told this story but I feel like your
audience might appreciate it or think
this is terrible but uh they I remember
I I we have a newsletter right so in
that newsletter I felt like our subject
lines were getting really stale I didn't
like them so I told the team I bet you
$1 thousand doll no matter what you come
up with on this newsletter I'm going to
beat your subject uh line and my team
was like yeah sure there's like three of
us and you're not really that involved
in this so let's go like great so it's
about landscaping or tree trimming or
something it's about tree trimming
thrilling yeah so sexy right and so it's
it's about making money with tree
trimming and their titles were like this
guy made X doing y this guy trimmed
trees and had XYZ and there were a
couple of them that were slightly more
clever and I was like now we're going to
AB test them and I go mine is I love
guys with wood dot dot dot which do you
think did better of course this one
that's slightly offs Spectrum it's still
true so it's not complete C clickbait
but it makes you feel something when you
see it is going to do better and so
that's just marketing and sales 101 and
that's also attention 101 like if you
have a Tinder profile you're probably
better off having something slightly
controversial so I bet women would
engage with that more like a KKK Hood
probably not that far all right okay
that's not I don't know if the Brits
really know what was happening there but
fair enough uh reading as a diet be
careful what you read it becomes the way
you think words are heard then
internalized then repeated and then
habituated curate what you let into your
brain as you do with your body this got
me onto an idea I had a while ago about
the content diet so most people
especially now especially in Austin
Jesus are super super concerned is there
seed oils in this what's the amount of
glucose tell me if this has been
responsibly sourced and like it better
be from an organic farm are there any
pesticides did somebody that had the
vaccine live within 10 miles of where
this cow was like you know getting milk
drawn from it um and yet when you look
at the YouTube suggested feed it's just
limic race to the bottom of the brain
stem Ben Shapiro destroys like panel of
leftist like you know it's it's the
stuff that the guilty pleasures that
many people like to watch and yeah it
got me thinking about if the cells in
your body are made up from the food that
you put in your mouth your brain is made
up of the things that you watch and
listen and read and given that your
content diet should be Spirulina for the
soul rather than fast food for your
Milla it's a great line by the way
spirina for the soul bookmark trademark
yeah I love that um what I found about
reading is I can immediately see the
contagion of greatness when I read it
and then I take action so if you go and
you read Charles Bukowski's best pieces
and then you go to write your writing
will be uplifted by this contagious
effect of greatness rubbing off I don't
know what it is I don't know if there is
a framework work or philosophy as to why
but I found the same thing with looking
at deals often when I go to invest in a
company I look beforehand at what did
Warren Buffett say in his last memo
about how he analyzed a company and you
can actually I think steal from the
minds of others by figuring out what you
allow into your brain and then applying
that immediately to what you do so it's
not just in The Ether all the time what
are you listening to but right before
you go take an action if you're going to
go into the gym you know usually maybe
you're taking some sort of pre-workout
right and then when you're in the gym
you're putting in some hardcore rap or
whatever you listen to when you work out
you buff dudes and then when you're done
with the gym you might go SAA or
whatever but the influence that you have
right prior if you have a giant dut or
steak immediately prior and you listen
to Lana Del re is going to be a
different experience than if you do the
former why would we think it would be
any different with any other aspect of
our life and so I have now applied that
pretty aggressively to the very few
things that I know Drive most of My
Success
which is before I'm writing before I'm
investing before I'm hiring who can I
steal from to get some of their
intelligent oh it's like an intellectual
aphrodesiac yeah exactly yeah I think
that's right I still like spirina for
the soul better but I thought that was
good too keep that keep that rolling
yeah I um the content thing the priming
yourself who do you want to be around I
love you know I know that he's like an
unspeakable guy because you promoted the
[__] lockdowns or whatever when I Ry
holiday and I kind of get this it's much
more pedestrian Pace yeah to kind of
what's going on and I imagine as every
man does that I'm in the Roman Empire uh
I imagine that I'm walking through you
know the Roman Forum or the sto poay
below the uh pathon in Athens and you
just get this much slower sort of pace
of life and Pace I'm sure if I looked at
my HRV and my resting heart rate it
would come down you know I'm just
thinking about ideas and I'm it's
couched in this much
slower slower sort of existence and um I
really really enjoy that and you know if
I was to then go in and try and have a a
difficult conversation I think I'd feel
more resilient if the alternative is
watching a whatever podcast like we
kicked these only fans thoughts out like
can you believe what Candice Owens said
to this like such and such a person it's
like well guess like what dreams I'm
having tonight like I want dreams here's
a good metric uh me and George Mac have
been talking about the difference
between hidden and observable metrics
and we're trying to come up with some of
the greatest hidden metrics that tell
you whether your life is going well or
not one of his that was pretty
contrarian was the number of hours per
year that you spend in a hammock is like
a really [__] great hidden metric of
how well your life's going that like if
you spend a good few hours in a hammock
per year it's like it's probably pretty
good I would say the number of hours
that you have having dreams about the
Roman Empire would probably be a a
strong uh a strong but yeah um hidden
and observable metrics [__] obsessed
with this idea at the moment I like it
well we even on our fridge Chris and I
have my Chris is my husband not you
Chris other Chris and um he one of his
favorite quotes is from Marcus aelius
that is the something along the lines of
um throughout your day assume that the
people that you meet will be miserable
Wicked uh selfish Etc and do right
anyway something that and I always
chuckle with it because you know my
husband is so he's a very int dude and
he has incredibly high expectations
former military Navy SEAL um and expects
humans to be honorable and to do the
right thing and to be thoughtful and uh
turns out most humans are not like that
and so I bought it for him as a reminder
coming back into the civilian world that
unfortunately this Warrior culture that
he has been in is not normalized and
thus if you can start your day every day
with really low expectations it turns
out that often the days surprise you and
so that has been helpful for us too
ideas strongly stated and loosely held
having a strong opinion is the mark of
intellect but having the ability to
change it is the mark of true
intelligence only politicians hold one
stance forever for fear of flip-flopping
we Mortals do better to constantly
experiment yeah I um I've recently spent
some time with Vivic ramaswami uh the
presidential candidate um and also spent
a lot of time with uh other political
candidates who are high up named or
won't name and um and what I've been
impressed by with uh let's say two of
the candidates on one on each side of
the aisle has been that they played in
the realm of business where numbers
mattered and outcomes were obvious and
so you either win or lose in business
there is a scorecard every single day
and every single year and you only stay
in business if you continue to win in
the scorecard and um and what I like
about vivi's perspective I don't agree
with him on everything but he has
changed his mind on many things and what
sort of business leader or human would
you be if you couldn't change your mind
once you had increased inputs that would
be absolutely wild you find out X and
you say nope already made up my mind on
this and yet that is what we expect of
our politicians often and our leaders
like well this guy changed his mind
think [__] god thank God there is a
human out here who continues to think
not just in sound bites but in full
Nuance so I've got this idea about the
unreliable Ally and basically somebody
who's a mono thinker that uh is sticks
rigorously to the party line that's
ideologically pure they are very
predictable for the future which means
that they make a really great Ally
because you know that no matter how much
new information comes to them they're
not changing their mind y so yeah I I
can totally see why that would be uh a
good signal that you want in a friend
but a totally terrible one that you want
in a political Ally right because you
don't know what if the what if things
change a lot over the next couple years
and they switch parties oh my God you
know yeah I think you're right yeah we
we kind of talk about um choosing sides
I do think it's really important to have
humans who will choose difficult sides
but not have strong opinions once they
learn new information and so my husband
and I always talk about the fact that um
you can really I think what you what
people want but they don't know how to
look for it is most humans what you want
is somebody who will stand by you even
when the mob won't when things are
irrational somebody will stand by you
because they know who you are as a human
being that is what we want in our lovers
that is what we want in our friends and
in our colleagues and instead of looking
for somebody who has overtime taken
courageous stances you look for somebody
who has continued to follow set Norms in
order to put them in a box and I think
that's the mismatch If instead we looked
for people who no they took a really
difficult stance on this even though
that was detrimental actually to their
wellbeing I would rather side with that
person then well this person has done
the party line continuously and so I
could assume the outcome here two really
good models for this when was the last
time in fact more when was the last time
that you heard this person change their
mind like can you recall when they said
I was wrong about X and especially if
they they're front and center about it
secondly how often did there opinions
surprise you right I think about so many
of the creators online that are big and
I know tell me something's going to
happen Russell Bran's being accused with
a a me too thing there you go I know
every single person in this lineup's
opinion right I can predict it with 100%
accuracy interesting the most as far as
I can tell good faith genuinely
intellectually virtuous people are the
ones who every so often are going to do
something you go really you think that
WR I don't agree or that might be wrong
or whatever say what you want about Sam
Harris I know he's like the least cool
guy on the internet at the moment and
everyone wants to keep dunking on him
despite the fact he's not on Twitter he
continually Trends on Twitter um but I
have good faith that he believes what he
says that counts for a lot but the
problem is unreliable really unreliable
Ally right third thing final thing is
how many different problems does this
person explain with the same solution so
if all of the issues of the world if all
of the problems are because of climate
change or all of the problems are
because of racism or all of the problems
are because of capitalism like oh your
demand for answers outstrips your supply
and because you only have this much
worldview and perspective you just
retrofit the one answer you have to all
of the problems that are in front of you
yeah one of the things that I found most
interesting is when we're analyzing
companies the best companies and their
Founders they do this one thing they say
here's the action I want to take and
here's our company I'd love you to poke
holes in it and tell me the things you
think I'm missing and they are actively
looking for disagreement because they
don't want to be right they want to win
and most people who want to win all we
care about is we want to information
gather we want to always be connecting
dots and we can only connect dots if we
see more of them and so the winners are
usually the ones that will ask you tell
me what I'm doing wrong tell me what I'm
missing here I think this but I I am
open to persuasion one way or the other
and it was funny because we actually did
a a little mini podcast the other day
and I was so irritated because I had
this person on because they had an
incredible tweet that I was like oo
spiky point of view I want to talk about
that then they came on and they just
soft softened it and they waffled it and
they didn't at all stick by what they
had said and and I I was I was poking
I'm like did you change your mind on
this like do you think something
differently and they're like no what I
meant to say was like no what you meant
to say is that you got kind of called
out for this and your strengths and
beliefs were overcome by other people's
opinions and likes and those type of
people once that happens to me once with
somebody I realize hey those can be an
acquaintance but they'll never be in the
Inner
Circle I had an
interesting lesson that I learned which
relates to something that you had here
the the gift of descent sick aants yes
men will kill you faster than descent
surround yourself with unruly
individuals who make you stand your
ground or berate you for not that's
exactly the same as what you were just
talking about yeah we um you know one of
our job one of my favorite job
descriptions of all time is the uh
Shackleford job description which is um
Shackleford went to the went to
Antarctica right and wrote this little
tiny job description that now has been
used all over the Internet about you
know High likely Hood to die looking for
adventurous Souls um you know who who
want the ability to fail greatly
basically and one of the things I talk
about with our team and the people that
we hire continuously is you want to look
for the people who get off on the heart
like you want to look for the people who
when there is a potential to fail and
when something is difficult is when they
get interested and if it's not that
interesting they're probably not going
to to participate and those F humans are
relatively rare because in today world
we want to succeed so badly uh and it
seems like we have repercussions that if
we do fail there's something wrong with
us and yet most of the most successful
people I know have just failed
prolifically continuously and yet
iterated and learned on it um and so you
know on our team one of the other things
that that we do and you know Tanner's
here so he could tell you if I'm lying
or not but uh like I find that if you
are a manager of humans if you are a
leader of humans and your humans don't
disagree with you often
then you probably are not a leader of
humans you're a director you're somebody
who they work for because they have to
but you haven't actually inspired
somebody enough to tell you their true
thoughts one way or the other and that's
usually what kills companies faster than
anything is a series of Yes Men
surrounding somebody who should have
been told no the problem as well is if
you don't have people who will tell you
what reality is showing you your own
obfuscation and biases and blindness
will never get corrected and presuming
that you start to continue to make
progress over time the impact of your
decisions continues to get bigger and
bigger and bigger yeah and that means
that at the time when your impact and
the magnitude of what you choose to do
is at its greatest your ability to see
what reality's feedback to you is is at
its lowest and you've had this Emperor
has like Emperor's New Clothes [__]
scenario right yeah for God knows how
long and it means that you you're
completely out of touch yeah it's true
well I even joke with my husband that uh
you you should tell me when I look fat
please do because I don't want to hear
that from somebody else first of all
second of all it's not healthy for me to
be that way so in fact I would want
nothing more than the humans that are
closest to me to tell me the hard thing
first before I go out and people tell me
I have no clothes or I look awful in
this and where is it okay in society
where we say oh it's just a little white
lie yeah they didn't look great but I
lied to them why would you want to be
lied to by somebody that you know loves
you you you certainly won't get lied to
by people who don't and so let's front
you know let's front run the pain so
that we could have some short-term pain
maybe even in private instead of of
suffering over the long term um well
actually we were talking about our
mutual friend horos before and I'm a I'm
like many people a super people pleaser
like actually I'm really bad at my core
which is probably why we're semi- good
at media we can have empathy and
understanding which leads to uh
Association
and um and so I'm really bad at that
which means that sometimes I'm too
agreeable and later I'll be like ah I
didn't agree with that why did I why did
I say that thing and why did I say yes
to this when I shouldn't have been
saying yes to this and so you know he
jokingly has become my captain no and
I'll just say I don't feel like saying
no to this I'm going to screenshot to
you anytime I don't and you just tell me
no because I already know I should say
no and then I'm going to start
screenshotting you when I actually do
and so we trade back and forth knows
because the more successful you get the
more questions and requests you're going
to have and you don't learn to say no
you won't be successful there's like a
kind of cringey V video of Elon musk's
first wife uh did you see that where she
she basically says it's just cringey in
that in how it's displayed but the
message is incredible and the message
she basically says is I had a very
successful husband I watched him for a
long period of time the number one
reason he was the most successful is he
had an amazing amount of requests paced
upon him and he learned to say no better
faster and more frequently than anybody
else and I was like if Elon Musk says no
a lot that probably means there's
something good happening there how have
you overcome your felt sense to want to
be a people
pleaser um practice practice saying no
as often as possible uh with kindness
every single time and brevity every
single time so somebody asked me the
other day
um they wanted to to to style me or
something can I you know pick out your
clothes
and uh and normally I would say oh you
know I'm okay right now but thank you so
much you know I'm I actually don't need
that or I just bought new clothes or I'd
have some excuse and now it is no thank
you I hope you're well no period end of
story the second that you allow one
other sentence behind the word you have
allowed an optin so if instead I say no
I don't really need it right now what's
the optin well what about later you know
if I say no I'm I already bought some
clothes it's like well what about uh I
give you some clothes and so what I
found is we allow our concern for
hurting other people's feelings to open
a door that just means we sound like
more of a dick later because oh yeah we
could have said no fast up front but we
should have said it later yeah then the
other truth is you will people will be
pissed at you about this people will be
upset I'm sure it happens to you all the
time I'm almost thankful I don't have a
podcast because I could only imagine the
amount of times interesting people that
you really like ask to be on this
podcast C and you have to say no thank
you and no matter how you do it and no
matter how you phrase it that is always
going to feel a certain way to a person
one of the problems that you encounter
if you don't end up learning to be able
to say no fully is that you have a kind
of like a wave swell underneath the
surface of these first you kick a can
down the road and then you kick a couple
more cans down the road and then before
you know it you have this overlapping
number of cans that turned into a
[__] tornado and you're all you spend
your time doing is kicking cans uh and
that is born out of a fear of
disappointing people uh I sat next to a
mutual friend of ours uh and he referred
me to a therapist that worked with him
and I was like I've tried therapy before
a couple of times and like mixed mixed
uh results out the other side of it but
if she can deal with this guy's [__]
she can definitely deal with mine cuz
he's a [__] so I uh I've I've
started I've started um going back into
therapy and and spending some time with
her which is really really fascinating
to be on the receiving end of questions
for once to supposed to be the person
giving them and uh the people pleasing
thing is just such a a huge huge block
for me it's such a difficult thing for
me to get past and I was starting to see
it in a lot of other people because a
lot of the time you see people's uh
politeness or the way that they move
through the world as an accurate
portrayal of their valtion or their
intention it's what they actually meant
to do and you go no it's not think about
all of the things all of the ways that
their desire has been perturbed right I
thought this was what you actually meant
to do but what you meant to do was the
opposite but you were so shy or tired or
nervous or hung over or you didn't want
to upset this person or you'd had an
argument with your boyfriend that or
whatever it was so the other thing
happened from the outside what you see
is oh that's what they meant to happen
from the side it's this you know game of
tennis and pingpong between two choices
10,000 times in a minute and then they
go oh yeah we'll do that thing you go
wow so yeah that's kind of opened my
eyes to the world of people I I was like
a secret member of the people pleaser
club and I never knew well I bet people
on the internet would be surprised that
you would say you were a people pleaser
and that I would say I was a people
pleaser because we have some rough edges
on the internet we'll take some
difficult stances but I've almost found
that people who take difficult stances
have learned to do it because we too
often didn't in spite yeah and so it's
you're scared and you don't want to take
the difficult stance but you do it
anyway I think there's very few humans
you know maybe Donald Trump has learned
to like you know the pain of to be the
heel right but I actually I've never met
a person even who was quite abrasive who
said that they didn't have some
discomfort with controversy pushing back
have you ever met one Michael mes okay I
don't know who that is uh he is a
cultural commentator professional troll
on the internet he's like the lowkey of
politics and he likes it oh he [__]
lives for it yeah he absolutely lives
for it another interesting one Warren
Buffett doesn't optimize wake up at 5:00
a.m. meditate work out drink 72 ounces
of chloride water and stand upside down
okay or do none of those things and
instead focus on thinking clearly
intently and strategically before you
pull any triggers this relates to an
absolute monster from Alex which was uh
your fears about perfection will kill
you more quickly than your imperfections
yeah yeah this was an OG one of mine
often I think if you want success you
should look at those who have had the
thing that you already want and so I was
getting caught up in this series of
noise surrounding all the shs that are
in my life that are actually not needs
and um and so I went to one of the
people that I admire the most which is
at least from a business perspective
Warren Buffett and I looked at what his
day was and you know the [__]
drinks Coke every day uh you know he's
eating McDonald's uh cheeseburgers he's
uh not working out and hasn't for a
while and he largely sits and thinks and
reads a newspaper every single day and
when I looked at that I thought well he
has basically realized that there's a 10
to 20% that drives the 80% and so now
I'm in a thing right now where I'm
trying to be healthier and work out more
and try to get a sixpack and whatever
the cool kids do and uh and I have this
trainer right now that I really like but
he has me you know tracking my steps
every day tracking my macros
uh inputting a workout where like check
the box and how much am I lifting and
what I finally said to him is what are
the two things we could do where if we
did those two things everything else
gets easier and my team gets tired of
hearing me say this but I'm like you
have a list 400 lines long of to-do list
items just like everybody else does and
yet you spend your time ticking them off
as opposed to thinking is there one
snowball in which if I pushed it
everything else became easy and you know
for for working out for instance there's
one snowball which is if I just
pre-order a set number of meals each
week from the same provider I don't have
to track my macros because I've had the
guy track it already and I know what it
is and you could do that even if you
just ordered Chipotle every single day
and so there's no monetary reason why
you wouldn't have to do it and uh this
tracking in the app every single day
ridiculously doesn't have to happen and
it's the same thing for a workout well
what if I just do the same workout every
single day uh or three rotations of it
for one month and then I rotate again
for you know uh to have diversity in my
training and instead of that we layer
all this complexity which makes
absolutely no sense to me and so um I
like cold plunging I like you know some
lemon in my water but I think we'll be
fine if we skip it every now and then
yeah and the concern about the over
optimization often gets in the way so
much and makes you fret I'm worried what
if I what if I don't show up
sufficiently effectively I had uh ran
Doris on the show do you know him from
flow research Collective neuroscientist
researcher in flow and um he's brilliant
he taught me that if you're bothered
about flow the best thing that you can
do as a morning routine is work within
90 seconds of waking oh that makes me
feel better about what I actually do
yeah yeah it depends I I don't think
that what he meant by work was
frantically answer emails with lots of
capital letters um but I don't actually
do my own email so i' better that that's
good um but my point being his thing is
get up with within 90 seconds of waking
right not of getting out of bed of
waking be at your desk interesting
working especially if you need to do
deep work writing creative stuff uh and
I've done this on weekends um with my
newsletter which I do on a Monday I
release on a Monday so I'll be writing
away and it seems to work pretty quickly
the reason the argument is that uh Delta
and Theta uh sleep and uh flow brain
wave states are right next to each other
so it's actually easier to slip from
sleep into flow than it is typically
from daily I've just walked the dog and
got caught in traffic into flow even
though you might think God I'm I'm only
just awake this is stupid it seems to be
the case at least the Neuroscience backs
it up yeah I mean there's a great book
that I can't remember the name that
talks about um all the varied habits of
the greats and their morning and evening
routines 5:00 a.m. Club Robin sha right
and then there was a a New York um
author as well that tried all of them
and then also did a YouTube series
series on them which was hysterical you
know because it was like some of the
great writers you know basically like
got up at 3:00 a.m. snorted a light of
cocaine started writing until they got
so hungry they needed a drink and then
they kept writing I mean ridiculous
right um but what I've realized is um
you know I think the Muse loves habits
whatever those habits are for you the
Muse really likes when you continue to
show up in the same way day after day
and whatever that way is you can decide
by and large but the Common Thread I've
seen for Successful People is they have
a process they have a flow and to try to
project that on another person is like
to try to say that you should eat this
when I know nothing about your genome
and how you work and so for me I get up
early I do a cold plunge because I like
I'm groggy in the morning I do it for
like way less than I probably should or
any scientific benefit I grab a coffee
and I get to work and that works for me
right now but see in a year the only
thing that I know will be consistently
true is I will have a process I follow
every single morning because I do not
believe that you wait for for the Muse
for whatever you do I think you go and
you grab it and you tell them to show up
at 8: a.m. just like you will very
Steven press Fieldy boredom as a
superpower the best ideas need Breathing
Room they're a flower stretching for the
sun clutter them with meetings and watch
them die instead he clears his schedule
every morning with no calls prior to
10:00 a.m. I do the same paired with two
no call days a week yeah I'm pretty
religious about this um my team knows
that I only take calls or meetings on
Monday Wednesday Friday I will
substitute something like a podcast for
a Tuesday Thursday or a speech but
nothing continuous um because what I've
realized is you know as you get more
successful you really have one job and
that is to find that 10 to 20% that
drives the 80% and it takes digging it's
needle in the Hast stack work it's not
stacking up Hast stacks and what most
people do all day is they stack Hast
Stacks they do the same thing
continuously every single day but what
do we know about normal normal equals
results we don't actually want and so um
I find that if I do not allow my ideas
room to breathe I'm anxious frustrated
kind of uncreative and probably come up
with more problems and solutions hidden
metric how many hours per year are you
spending being bored I bet that that
would be correlated with the quality of
your life and you're flourishing as well
more time being bored would be good I
think they say that there that is true I
wonder though it depends what type of
bordedom of course by by the definition
of what we're talking Club yeah yeah not
bored with someone giving you a rubbish
speech a presentation at work but like
walking through nature allowing your
mind to flow as it wishes right pretty
good hidden metric very much so and so
what would we call that instead it it's
it's not really boredom it's like it's
not quite rumination I guess imagination
time yeah it's it's basically when are
you when are you in a non action taking
State how often can you be in something
where you're not entertaining and you're
not taking action I had this
conversation with with John LEL from the
warrior Poet Society okay big uh like
military guy Pro Patriot guy uh also big
Christian guy and he was episode 666 and
I got a [__] ton of uh Kickback in the
comments because people like I can't
believe that you put like John on
episode 66 we needed a man like John to
battle the devil's number and I was like
I did I it was just a Saturday right to
me it was just a Saturday I didn't think
but anyway cool um and he taught me this
term which I [__] love I think he'll
enjoy as it's called the tyranny of the
Urgent oh yes oh so good the tyranny of
the Urgent and there's this like a quote
or something that either he has or
somebody else has about that oh okay
it's not his I didn't know he well I'll
have to find it you are the you have the
memory for quotes but something to the
degree of um if you let the tyranny of
the Urgent overwhelm the important uh
you'll never achieve something like that
we can have the internet tell me I'm
wrong and say the right words um but I
think that's that's very very true I
also find the most like if you're
particularly frazzled it's probably
because you are focused on urgent and
not important and those who focus on
important not urgent kind of Coast their
way through life I mean to go back to
Bill Perkins because I adore the guy I
remember when I showed up at his house
the first time I was late so I was
frazzled I'm Latina I'm basically always
late and I'm an over Schuler so I was
doing way too many things and as I got
there he was he was so calm while making
more money than I do and having more
businesses than I do and I was you know
I was kind of like Bill what do you got
going on today he's like this is the day
I'm like what's what's this he's like
you this conversation with you is the
day it's the most important thing that I
have to do today and I just thought
that's fascinating and even when I talk
to his wife she's like yes he's quite he
will move very quickly between
activities he'll get out of bed he will
immediately get on a phone call but the
things that are important he will allow
a ton of space on either side yeah he's
not swamped by the Urgent yeah he seems
to have a lot of uh
an awful lot of time here's another
hidden metric I'm just throwing this out
out at you uh the average speed that you
walk at I bet that if it's bet if it's
reduced down the average speed you walk
at per year is like a really lovely
metric of I'm just [__] I got time
man except if you're at the airport can
we have you know if you're at the
airport because you should always spend
as little time as possible at the
airport yeah and you should just get out
of people's way it's like number
actually you know what there's two
things I think I agree with you on when
necessary walking with conviction but uh
not franticness is an interesting one I
think the counter opposite is show me
how long it takes you to order at a
counter and I will show you your bank
account I think the longer people take
in I this had me happened to me the
other day and I about lost my mind but I
was at a counter like one does a coffee
shop or something and there was a
there's always a lady in front of you
right and the lady in front of you takes
four centuries to order order a coffee
and a muffin and what I realize very
quickly is you know if you want to get
something done you give it to a busy
person is the saying and I think often
that's why they say you should take
somebody to dinner before you hire them
or take them out to lunch see how they
treat the staff but I also think see how
quickly they make decisions because
people who take forever to order when
they stand in line one are really
comfortable inconvenience in somebody
else around them which means they have
limited self-awareness maybe borderline
narcissism and then simultaneously
they're not very efficient at the things
that don't really matter that coffee
order does not really matter and so if
we know we are here for fin out amount
of time why spend so much time on that
as opposed to a walk a sunset Etc low
tolerance for uncertainty as well oh yes
you really didn't like this lady did you
uh speaking of that the Toleration
challenge what if your intellect is
measured by how much truth you can
tolerate can you be told you're wrong
and that dress makes you look fat and
you're getting older and he's smarter
than you and take them all in stride
yeah um my husband and I basically have
a thing where something annoyed me
yesterday actually and instead of
typically what do we want from our
partners when something annoys us we
typically want the other person to just
go yeah [__] that guy yep agree you were
right he was wrong and instead we make
it sort of a purpose of saying all right
what are we going to learn from this um
and so he gave me some feedback that I
didn't really like I was like who's
whose side are you on and yet that
practice helps us us because if we don't
associate with you know to get woo woo
because we're located here in Austin we
know that you know we're not our body
because we can have thoughts that change
as our body changes you know we know
we're not our job because our jobs can
change we know we're not the way that we
look because if something terrible
happens to us we're still there so if we
know we're not all of these things why
would you let it control so much of your
brain for you to be seen one way or the
other about them and it's something I
think about a lot because we're on the
the internet which means our reflection
is thrown in our face constantly and
often other people's reflection of
themselves is thrown in our face
constantly and because of that I don't
think you can have thin skin and be on
the internet that's actually kind of a
beautiful thing because you learn none
of it really matters we will all die
eventually and every one of us will be
forgotten and there's such Liberty there
the way that that gets uh perverted is
people go from it doesn't matter I can
have unbounded dreams to it doesn't
matter nothing that I do makes any
difference right it's the uh nihilism or
cynicism versus optimism helicopter
thinking seesaw and it seems to be bit
of a knife edge between the two um but I
also agree that if you have
a if you have a partner or a friend or
somebody who regularly will compromise
what's true in order to tell you what's
convenient or comfortable that are
actually like really rubbish should why
bother asking them anything because
every single question that they hear is
not what is the truth about this thing
it's what do you think I want to hear
from you that's every single question is
is the same question what do you think
that I want to hear from you and then
that you say that and again that's the
the people pleaser thing what else have
you learned from Bill Perkins he was
instrumental in bringing you down to
earth in a pretty big way I think yeah
well he was funny um I think our first
interaction uh I consider myself
relatively successful and uh and so when
I went to meet with him and I told him
about some of the things we were working
on he had this line that stuck with me
that I wish I could just like put on a
bumper sticker somewhere um which was I
was explaining all these things we're
working on we're buying these companies
here and here we're growing and he kind
of looked at me and paused like he does
and he's like uh Cody do you think that
you have been investing in small
businesses for so long small has it
infected your thinking I was like and an
immediate reaction could have been like
who are you [__] you I don't know uh and
instead I took a pause and I was like
God there's so much freedom in that line
what if I am thinking too small and
somebody else who has had a past history
of positive performance says that then
what might might I be capable of and so
I almost wish all of us a friend that
pushes us harder as opposed to is the
shoulder to cry on and says like you
know what I'd like you to do next time
is something else in fact we have
another mutual friend that I was talking
to that did something really big and
really successful and uh and they came
to me because they're a high performer
and they were like what what should I
have done different what should we have
done different and I was like I think
one and I want you to hear this
everything you did was incredible I'm so
impressed by you and and I think you
should keep going and then I said
secondly there's this one thing that you
did that was a mimic of somebody else
and what if that would have been been a
totally Unique Style to you and that's
what I want to see from you next time I
think you are capable of coming up with
your own style that is totally copiable
and she was like God thanks because what
everybody else said was positives
positives positives and very few people
will tell you yeah but what if you could
do this one thing not that you're shitty
but like what if you could do this one
thing better wouldn't that be cool two
stories that come to mind first one Lex
fredman uh was at some party neurod
Divergent degenerates at Michael
malice's house and and I was talking to
him about I think he
was I think he was saying that he had a
lot of work on at the moment and he was
doing his robotic stuff and he's doing
the podcast and maybe the Ukraine
conflict was was going on too and he was
just feeling it feel all of this stuff's
going on blah blah blah I was like oh
interesting and then he like took a
pause and he said I wish that my friends
would stop comforting me when I say that
I work hard yeah because some of his
friends
say you already work so hard Lex you
know you should go easier on yourself
like this is you're doing a lot as it is
he said that he really really values the
friends that say yeah this is tough but
you're tougher 100% you know even my
mother she had an incredible line to me
she basically said and it's so simple
but we don't hear it enough you just
continue every single day to do the best
that you can and only you know what the
word best is defined as and most people
put some subjective best hard good bad
on you as opposed to saying I believe in
you so much that you know what you are
capable of and only you can answer if
you are actually living up to that on a
daily basis and I love that because I
actually think most humans are very
capable should they apply themselves
continuously and work past a point that
is comfortable or even rational and if
you can do that you can achieve very
many things pending you don't want to be
a basketball player and you're you know
5-1 like pending those things you can
achieve much and that's part of the
reason I'm so prevalent on the internet
now is you know I made a lot of my money
already in in finance and doing the
things that I did previously and then I
realized ah I want to make more money
because it's fun I really like every
dollar I make but I think it's more
interesting if I could figure out could
I help other people actually achieve the
same thing and not because I'm nice I'm
really not that nice but just to see
like is that Poss because that seems
like a more interesting and bigger
Legacy actually than just can I apply
this one thing continuously and so um
lots of people who are on the internet I
think people say one thing or the other
about humans like us that talk about
things publicly and yet thank God that
there are humans like you who talk about
things like neurod Divergent being
normal because I thought that just used
to mean well you know I have a little
bit of ADHD which means I'm defunct in
some way um and so
yeah I think most humans can work harder
and they just don't want to hear that
you're getting perilously close to
chat's man in the arena tweet which is
going to get you destroyed on I actually
have actually used that before I do
think you know what [__] that I think if
you own a small business and you are a
business owner now maybe not chamath in
the sweaters and jets at this point
maybe you have a lot of buffer there but
I actually don't know his life so I
don't know um but I think if you are a
small business owner and you are working
really hard out there you're in the
arena yeah and and I think my husband
who went to war multiple times would say
the same thing counts as it definitely
counts as an arena yeah some sort of
difficult and we should we should
actually praise people for that a little
bit more you remember when Elon took
over Twitter and um he said he gets rid
of 95% of the coding team wild Dev team
whatever and I think he puts out a
job application web page and says
something like if you want to work
harder than you've ever worked in your
entire life come to Twitter and people
criticized him on the internet and said
this is a return to you know early 1900
sweat shop labor what is this are we
going to be going down chimney
sweeping and I understand that in a
world where we can have much more
luxurious uh working conditions and
everybody can have their mindful Mondays
and they can have their latte Wednesdays
stuff like that and that's not just to
mock it like I do think it's a in some
regards a much more balanced holistic
culture but what it fails to understand
is that there is a cohort of people out
there who just want to put their nose on
the grindstone and see how fast they can
make it spin like all they want to do is
work they love and are fired up and take
so much more pleasure from the idea of
achieving something completely
unreal with their time and it is a
failure of theory of mind for you person
on the internet to look at that job post
from Elon maybe it is exploitative maybe
it's uh fortunately um like a
coincidence that he can both use the
people's drive to be able to achieve
whatever they want and also like get
them basically a cut down price to work
24 hours a day perhaps but it is a
failure of theory of mind to understand
that there are people out there who just
want to do that and it would f him up
way more to be told here's an obscenely
unrealistic goal in a ridiculously short
time span and I want you to do it here's
as much Aderall as you need and a
comfortable standing desk let's see what
you can manifest yeah yeah I mean I was
uh so my husband was a a Navy SEAL and I
was at the it's like the 40th uh year
anniversary of his team Seal Team 3 and
uh I thought it was fascinating on a
couple different fronts one you looked
around the group of 600 people uh all
gathered and you could immediately pick
out uh all of the seals right out out of
uniform because it's become so rare to
be fit and healthy and have you know 200
people who are like that all in one
space 200 Warriors was really rare
thought that was interesting what I also
thought was interesting is I spoke to
them about it and I spoke to those who
had come out and those who are still in
is those who had come out had said do
you know what we miss more than anything
and I'm like the adrenaline
you know the operations kicking
down it was doing extremely difficult
things with other people who want to do
extremely difficult things well and that
level of of human who wants to excel is
just rare and so when you're around them
you feel it you know you feel a
difference between you have an energy
that is positively accelerated when
you're around another doer they just
they don't drain from meal because
they're too busy doing and pushing out
and with with the SEAL Teams I was never
in them I can't speak to any of it
myself but what I've seen is that these
guys miss that more than anything else
when they get out it's not just like
camaraderie it's we were excellent at
what we did and we held each other to an
incredibly high standard and we had a
joint purpose and I mean there was a
study done during the blitz right during
during the World War that everybody
talks about with humans were conceivably
happier as defined by uh lower suicide
rates during the blitz than uh
afterwards because there was the shared
purpose and meaning and so I think if
you compare your shared purpose and
meaning with a group of excellent humans
let go of all of those uh who do not
want to be excellent because cancer
spreads then you can create somewhere
where people want to spend 24 hours
working because Society at large looks
nothing like that and you can feel the
difference once did you learn looking
around a room of 200 seals 300 seals
what did you learn from looking at their
spouses well that's
interesting
um well the spouses probably fit in a
lot of ways two categories uh one
category would be more traditionall
looking sundresses you know cute kids
running around happy looking American
family and the other were just as jacked
as they you know just as as as like uh
strong and tat
uh as their men and so um I actually
thought that was an interesting
dichotomy and you see that like
Gabrielle Lion's a friend of mine and
she's a badass doctor and also just like
one of the strongest fittest women I've
ever met in my life is her husband a
seal her husband's a seal right and a
surgeon and uh and then uh Emily
forcella Andy Fella's wife also just
jacked in great shape um her husband
isn't a seal but like I do think that it
seems like really strong driven men that
our team guys either want sort of the
traditional spouse um you know sundress
Etc or like a very strong similar person
to them and when I've gotten to know a
lot of these guys and I have a lot of
respect for them and their spouses
there's two types of strengths there I
mean the the physically strong thing is
really important but you will not last I
mean the divorce rate among Team guys
and special operators in general is
incredibly high is it really oh yeah
it's the highest of any military um one
because they're gone all the time both
training and deployment um and two
because I've been you know through a
deployment with my husband and it's
emotionally taxing in a way that we are
not habitualized too and so um you have
to be strong enough to do that I I think
I would have struggled to do it with
kids like I have nothing but respect for
the women who have kids with men who go
into line of duty every day where they
could potentially die that's incredibly
difficult to live through what's the
reality of being married as a power
couple h
um you know what's so funny is everybody
says it's really hard and Chris and I
kind of look at each other every day and
we're like best part of my day right now
like we wake up in the morning you know
what I actually do in the morning I
don't get in the cold plunge first Chris
and I snuggle like little nerds for like
five or 20 minutes we're just like
snuggling talking to each other the dog
gets into the bed the dog's a little
tiny thing not even a cool looking team
Guy dog and uh and he's you know my
person who's somebody that I can just
trust and rely on and I think I'm that
for him too we loved the quote I
remember in the beginning when we were
first dating didn't age well because I
think it was Jeff Bezos who said uh I
married my wife because I wanted
somebody who could get me out of a third
world prison at any point uh but uh we
always kind of associated with that you
know our thing is it's us against the
world and so um I think that's the one
truth of being a power couple I I don't
know any different because I've always
worked so I've never been and my my you
know husband he's always worked and most
of my significant others were powerful
and successful in a traditional sense um
but one of the most incredible things I
think when you find another human who is
striving for something is you really can
track on what's going on in your lives
and there's a lot you can share whereas
at least from my perspective if I was
with a man who wasn't working very hard
uh in a job in some way shape or form
it's harder for for us to be on the same
page and I end up having to talk with a
lot of other people about the thing I'm
obsessing on all day long and I never
really understood how people could be
with like the trophy wife thing never
really made sense to me a trophy
girlfriend makes a lot of sense trophy
boyfriend makes a lot of sense a wife or
husband doesn't to me because what would
you talk about do you guys just look at
each other all day like what's happening
there and so I actually think that's
really shallow and we should all strive
to be the best versions of ourselves not
to mention do you remember that um there
was a blog post a million years ago
where the guy was like really brutally
said why would I ever have a trophy wife
or a trophy husband he was talking about
a trophy wife um and he's like and and
marry that person for just their looks
when your looks are definitely going to
depreciate over time and my assets will
appreciate over time and at the time I
remember being like yeah [__] that guy
and then I was like well also kind of
true makes a lot of sense if all we're
talking about is the way you look that's
pretty shallow and so I don't have a lot
of complaints and I think I wouldn't
last very long with somebody who wasn't
striving right alongside me what there's
a lot of talk and narrative on the
internet about the sort of alpha
polarity the you know super masculine
guy with the very feminine woman there
must be a leader there must be a
follower what is the dynamic like given
that you are two leaders yeah uh I sort
of have this Theory we'll see if it
plays out
you had the girl boss me too movement
right women power [__] guys we don't
need you then you had the Alpha Man
movement you know get behind me I'm the
protector I'm in charge you know women
stay home in your Gardens and I think in
the future what we're going to come back
to which is what we do every time we
have massive pendulum pendulum swings is
like uh yeah why don't we both kind of
chill out in the middle like that seems
like typically where we go and I think
there will be not an alpha power couple
but
what if we both just realized that we're
nuanced humans and we look for somebody
who could actually support us
continuously a bunch of the guys that
had that Alpha woman movement saying got
divorced like one of the main guys who
was like you must protect your family
you know do whatever and had a a woman
that was sort of this other thing gets a
divorce the other guy who's a big
proponent of it like Andrew Tate not
[__] married so like the people who
are talking about this Alpha Man
movement let's scoreboard it let's see
over time does this this work out for
you and I'm a big proponent of you
should do whatever you want but I think
I'm good friends with the hosis because
I watch them have each other's back
through time and that seems to me more
sustainable than the other way around
what do you think uh so I think that
there is a significant cohort of women
who are like you attracted to guys who
have
Excellence but don't have that same
drive themselves don't think that the
reverse is quite as true for men I don't
think you're going to find a normal dude
who chugs away at a perfectly acceptable
job but it's like you know I really get
turned on by like Boss [__] women that
are like you know like high powerered
lawyers and stuff because the
socioeconomic status of a woman doesn't
matter as much to a man on average as it
does in Reverse so I think that
ultimately being competent as a man and
this is is you to cut through three and
a half years of learning evolutionary
psychology whether it be status whether
it be resources whether it be looks
whether it be height whether it be being
funny whether it be being Charming or
whatever like just portraying competence
right but competence comes on both sides
of the equation and the polarity can be
changed with quite nicely because you
know if you see as a husband if you see
your wife just like a [__] wizard
with the kids you know and the the all
three of them are ready for school five
minutes early and the breakfast's done
and there's a kiss on the cheek and
she's out the door you're like yeah
you're a [__] boss like sure you're
not going off to the the office or
whatever but you've got this [__]
unlocked that's attractive a grade
players look for aade players right
regardless of sector correct regardless
of what the subgenre of game is that
they're playing yeah right that's right
and this is why you know very rarely do
you see in I've been watching that uh
quarterback on Netflix it's about three
different NFL quarterbacks and Patrick
Mahomes is one of them and you look at
all three of the wives of these guys all
three of them pretty well spoken they're
not you know super PR like uh I think at
least maybe two of them have been
together since before they were even in
college right so it's not like they've
picked up some like hot totty girl and
like moved her into the house or
whatever um
long-standing relationships but they all
all of the girls are like competent with
what they do like they they're able to
talk and they're able to explain and
they have insight about themselves and
they have insight about their partner
you're like H yeah that's like that's
hot that's cool right like it's
attractive competence is attractive and
incompetence is almost always going to
be unattractive that's absolutely true
yeah I mean I do think one one thing
I've found for women that I think women
really need to watch out for and I've
noticed this just among my friends cuz
I'm I'm a little bit older now and so I
have a lot of my friends who have had
kids and been married for a period of
time and a lot of them are highly
competent like you said we're incredible
mothers are incredible mothers have gone
through child birth multiple times which
still intimidates me and I find
incredibly impressive um and then I
found there's this there's this lull
period after your kids don't need you as
much anymore and you know your husband
has continued to progress in this linear
career progression and you poured
yourself with competence into your your
your kids and I think we will see in the
future a rising usage of uh prescription
pills sleeping aids Aderall um to this
subset of women because they start to
realize ah where do I go now and Society
doesn't really have this fit for me any
longer well what that typically or
traditionally would have been if we roll
back over 200 years we would have been
in pan generational houses right so it
would have been been assisting with my
sister's daughters or assisting with my
daughter's daughters assisting with my
niece assisting with my whatever right
you know there would be so much to do
it's called aloe parenting not many
animals do it but humans do where
multiple related and unrelated women
share the child rearing burden together
right because rearing a human child is
an effortful much better effortful task
so you share it between your friends and
your family and there's an idea do you
know why the evolutionary psychology
explanation for why menopause exists no
this is cool so it's called the
grandmother hypothesis grandmother
hypothesis says
that why would you have an animal female
animal that exists beyond their
reproductive window right if our goal is
to survive and reproduce as soon as you
stop reproducing surely kicking the
bucket makes a t of sense because get
out of the way let the calories go to
the ones that are going to be able to
survive if you can no longer make kids
but that doesn't account for the fact
that the very effortful rearing that's
required for human children so if you
imagine that you have a particular
fertility window after that point you as
grandmother can no longer produce
children that sap calories but can
contribute to the rearing of children
not only yours but your daughters and
your sisters and so on and so forth so
this is the grandmother hypothesis you
uh age out of your reproductive role and
move into a new kind of role so you are
still a net positive from a caloric
perspective to the whole tribe I thought
that was really interesting that's
fascinating it actually makes a lot of
sense um but I don't know what the
solution is for the modern day modern
day woman rough you know you've got Adam
Lan Smith tweeted this thing where he
said uh don't forget that moving out of
home at 18 is a scop by the real estate
industry uh like and in some regards
it's true right we would have always
lived in big pan generational houses
Farms commun type things um I I think
that you're right I think that as
Financial Independence becomes more
available to women its lack will be more
tightly felt right if you have
sacrificed a career that you already on
or never got into a career uh to be able
to raise the kids because you wanted to
be the greatest mother that you could
when that role is now gone it's like
being an NBA star you're 37 years old
right Jonathan come in sit down there's
your retirement check you've done really
great okay all I've known my entire life
or all that I can remember that I've
known for the last 15 years has been
ball or children yeah what where do you
take your sense of meaning from uh and
you know you see this I think uh uh the
Peterson talks
about the greatest sacrifice that a
mother can make is to allow their child
to go out into the world knowing that
they're fragile and he says
uh if you go out there you might lose
yourself but if you stay with me you'll
lose your soul and it's
this Michelangelo's P this uh beautiful
um marble sculpture that's in the
Vatican uh it's the mother with Christ
sort of draped across her arms like this
and he says that you know this it's the
Fe crucifixion it's not about you it's
about your child and uh it's rough I I
think that you're right I think that we
will see some some challenges there uh
that being said women have got really
really great performance in the
workplace at the moment and I don't
think that a 52-year-old uh mother of
two who is still conscientious as hell
and and super competent is going to
struggle to reintegrate back into a an
office working environment especially if
you've got all of the emotional
intelligence and all of the people
skills that have been developed over the
last two decades of raising a bunch of
tiny screaming kids like that's a skill
set I certainly know within my operation
that having like a mothering role
someone to just lubricate the wheels
socially I think that would be a really
cool like a like literally like a a
surrogate mother CU there's a lot of
like Lads I guess that work for me you
know 25 to 35
dudes and like just someone to come in
and be like boys can we stop doing X Y
and Z or someone's forgot the this thing
professional mother I think would be
culprit mother yeah I think we got a new
coin there um yeah well there's a couple
things one is uh I've never really
understood agism in the workplace
because if you actually employ older
people of both sexes um both people you
know let's say 50 60 and above the
immediate reaction is usually that they
have a deficit with technology which is
true as we will when we get to that age
but the flip side of that is actually
that their exper their lived experience
is so strong that when you hire somebody
like this they just have more rep they
have more reps on this planet and so I
saw the other day we were in a team
meeting and I have this one uh person on
my team shout out Kimberly and she's
great she's a mother of three and uh and
you know I saw one of our our
individuals in the team getting a little
flustered a gent and I was pretty
aggressive and direct which not usually
the best way to be when somebody is that
way and she as she probably does with
her three kids was amazing she was like
really calm she's like you know how are
you feeling about that like what do you
think and I would never ask a question
like how are you feeling about that I
need to work on my EQ and she did and I
do find that that aspect I hope to bring
back more Goldman actually had a great
program which was bringing women
re-entering back into the the workforce
I'm not sure re-entering back into
Goldman sounds great after I had been a
mom for a while um but I'm curious to
see what happens for that generation of
women and I think it'll be it'll be
really really cool and I also think my
husband and I work together in a lot of
capacities and he still has his he he
does work for the Department of Defense
um but that's another thing that people
say you should never do and I find
extreme joy in it um and I'd be curious
what would happen for more individuals
if Partners allowed their significant
other more into their sphere doesn't
mean you have to overlap entirely we
have very different Pursuits but when
you can watch your significant other
excel in something that you really
understand dayto day I don't think
there's anything sexier on both sides of
the equation it's competence plus
understanding right you're able to
interpret you watched someone be really
good at Brazilian jiu-jitsu or pickle
ball or drawing or something and you're
like honey you did great right you I'm
so proud of that thing you just did
which I don't largely understand and
actually if you were to look at some of
the most sought-after
Pursuits for uh guys because again the
increasing status that you get by being
competent at something seems to be
beneficial uh to men a little bit more
what they're actually looking at doing I
wonder if this is right what men are
looking at doing is trying to find
Pursuits that are the most easy to
interpret by the widest number of women
interesting music everybody can tell is
that good music or bad music but you
know how many people are like I'm going
to make uh like cyber Punk Drummond bass
I'm going to be the best cyberpunk it's
like yeah sure but it's not going to be
as broad uh comedy right movies
everybody watches movies everybody
watches comedy everybody watches listens
to music yep yeah exactly like I'm going
to be in shape I can see that I don't
kind of understand what's going on but
like I I know that's good or at least
other people think that that's good um
and that's another one signaling right
so you've got not only is it obviously
competent but do other people hold that
competence in high esteem again cyber
Punk drum and bass who who who even
knows if that exists but if you're in a
cohort of people who very much value
this thing you I remember when we were
doing Club promo so many times some of
the boys would use the term like she's
Instagram hot right which is like what
does that mean so she's she looks fit on
Instagram but in real life isn't quite
as hot but part of the hotness of the
girl on Instagram was impacting how
highly they regarded them in real life
interesting because you've got kind of
pre-selection right if this girl's got
more followers than everybody else and
everyone else is like looking at what
she's doing and everyone thinks that
she's really really fit online even if
she kind of isn't that in the real world
it's almost like a degree of competence
right beautification the ability to
beautify yourself and having a a style a
visual uh heal even if that doesn't
translate very much at all to the real
world is still a a thing right yeah
Well's true you know I was talking to to
a couple of entrepreneurs the other day
about um they delivered something and I
the end product was okay but the way
that they delivered it was poor and so I
call this the Tiffany's box Theory and
basically you know if you look at two
diamond rings that look identical to
them but one is from ziles and one is
from tiffy's this one from TI will have
a price tag of 50,000 and this one will
have a price tag of five it is the same
exact product there's literally no
difference except the name on one versus
the other and what is the real
difference between the two well if I was
to give you either one of those rings
and I like stuck in a paper bag and I
crumpled it up and I threw the paper bag
at you and then you got that ring you're
already pre-selected you already have a
bias to say what is this this is like a
fake ring this is whatever it wouldn't
actually matter that this was the
Tiffany's ring but if I gave you the
$5,000 ring and I put it in the
Tiffany's box box and I tied it up and I
presented it to you in this way you
would now value that ring at a $50,000
amount even though the difference
between a paper bag 25 cents and the
Tiffany's box I don't know $150 doesn't
actually equate at all to the value
that's changed between the two but if we
wrap something properly we will consider
it to be more valuable and that is like
rule number one in success business
probably sex love the way you present
the medium is the message that's exactly
right yeah think I I learned this from
Steven bartler a couple of weeks ago
really good example uh think about how
much space every Apple Store loses in
terms of real estate by not packing more
technology onto each table right go into
in the UK I don't know them over here
Target maybe I guess but like PC World
or curries in the UK like big
electronics stores uh go into there and
it's just a [__] chaos of cables
everywhere and screens are touching each
other because the most amount of
products that we can can put out means
that customers are able to find exactly
what they want you go into an Apple
store and there's just Barren Wasteland
in between each product all right so
couple of couple couple of interesting
questions for the guys who like the idea
of having a highly
competent driven smart
girl
what what are the dos and don'ts what
should those guys think about what are
they getting right and getting wrong in
your and your friend's experience that's
such an interesting question um well a
couple different things the easiest the
easiest way I think to attract a we need
to we should come up with a term for
this is there a term for like high value
woman oh God I don't want to use that I
know the origination also could you
imagine if I called myself a high value
woman or somebody calls themselves a
high value man I immediately there's
rule number one don't [__] call
yourself that good rule number two is um
I think a couple things people
underestimate if we're talking about the
rapping the rapping does not have to be
sixpack and hot to get a high value
woman it really needs to be confidence I
always joked with my husband he's like
he jokes because he's shorter so he's
like you know nobody's looking at this
and if you met him which have you met
him yeah you did meet him yeah yeah he
just takes up a room just the way that
he is his presence he's really not
afraid he's uh rather direct um he looks
you in the eye he walks up to you
specifically like he's supposed to be
there and so are you and he's actually
quite calculated on the method in which
he would communicate with you and so
because of that he could be not the 6'
five you know guy who's going to
naturally have uh an unfair advantage in
finding a partner um but he would have
this like un this satellite around him
that you just this magnet that you get
draw drawn towards and I found that with
a lot of the women I know who are let's
say tradition Ally goodlook successful
competent in some way shape or form
often their partners are people who have
an IT factor in some way and the cool
thing about an IT factor is you can
create it you could actually learn to be
the type of person who just shakes hands
with a little bit of strength and look
somebody in the eye and you can actually
learn to be the type of person that
listens and repeats back the thing that
the person just said to them and that's
a little bit curious and that chooses
not just to be nice but to be kind um
the other thing that I think people who
are uh competent on either side of it is
they want they want you to be courageous
in one shap way shape or form and it
doesn't have to be because you're a man
but they don't really care if you're the
um you know nice to oh yes of course
thank you um you know we don't really
want that overly nice thing what we
actually do want is that you notice the
guy on the side of the road who's having
a flat tire and needs a little bit of
help and you decide to pull over and see
what you can do to help the guy you
don't even have to know how to fix it
just call up and make something happen
and so I think this world of like humans
who make things happen end up running
into more humans who make things happen
because we're just busy doing the doing
and so um the cool thing I think about
if you want to find a woman who is a
strong you know partner in many Pursuits
is they really just want a woman or a
man who is also kind of strong in their
own Pursuits and some of my best friends
who have long-term marriages you know 10
years plus um to men who even aren't as
monetarily successful as them and some
of them are is that actually the way
that the man looks has very little to do
with it which I don't always find to be
true on the other side of the equation
um but they might have like some
incredible personality trait um and I
think that's just really attractive to
women what about the other side of the
fence what advice would you have for
your female Brethren who think I like
the idea of getting a competent partner
what are the ways the pitfalls that you
see those women fall into or what are
the things that they should be prepared
for or what are the ways that that can
go Ary if if they're looking for the the
competent man yeah um have you ever
proactively looked for a partner like
been looking and thinking a lot about
finding a partner uh no not particularly
no it's always kind of just upon me yeah
that's a common trait I found typically
I think people who are competent and
looking for that same thing in a partner
they focus on bettering themselves
before they focus on looking for another
I think the biggest red flag is
typically a a human who's like I really
just want to be with somebody I want to
be with somebody I'm ready how do I find
my person get that energy out of your
life as both a woman which I can speak
more to and a man and instead become
somebody worth finding and that's really
hard to hear I I think on either side of
the coin but when you start working out
which doesn't mean you have to be
perfectly fit but you have more energy
when you start pursuing something that
you're uniquely interested in when you
have real Pursuits that are obsessions
for you in some way shape or form form
you're more interesting and thus you
will attract more interesting people and
I think the biggest thing that we have
done wrong as a disservice to society
and you might have told me about this or
we might have talked about this before
is assume that finding the right person
is simply a game of swiping ref left
swiping right continuously I think one
of the worst things we've ever done is
allow dating apps to enter into our
dating equation because we have thought
that it is a numbers game of finding the
right person as opposed to a daily
activities game of becoming the right
person when you become the right person
you will attract people continuously no
matter what and I've seen this from both
myself and my friends who are varying
levels of attractive varying levels of
rich but working really hard on a few
things that make them very interesting
to humans yeah I think lots of people
ask the question where are all of the
good partners at right very few people
ask the question why am I not attracting
the kind of partners that I want to be
attracted to that's the question and
there's a a line from artificial
intelligence to zombies rationality from
a to zed by eled yuk outski and he
writes this book about rationality which
cognitive biases and the ways that our
thinking goes AR and stuff and at the
start part of it he says people take the
piss out of rationalists not because
being in love with rationality is
strange but because it's so love it's so
rare to love anything in the modern
world and this death of passion that
people have like if you ask someone what
do you really love doing like tell me
what gets you fired up if you had an
appointment at 7 in the morning to do
this thing you would be out of bed at 6
because you couldn't wait to go and do
it right and me and Zach my housemate we
always used the same example uh rally
cross so it's like the drivers in the
four-wheel drive cars and they're going
through wooded things and everyone dies
everybody dies all the time um and but
Do's these dudes that go in the [__]
pissing rain to Perth Scotland right in
November right at 300 p.m. on a
Wednesday afternoon with an anarak and a
a umbrella over the top of their head
some of them have got cameras some of
them haven't and they stand there to
watch a rally car
go like that and then they turn and look
at their boys and they're
like and we love watching those videos
because watching anybody else get fired
up at something that they love fires you
up right to see someone love anything is
so rare it's like an oasis right in a
desert of bland indifference oh yeah I
remember I knew I was going to get
divorced when um I'm divorced and
remarried I knew I was going to get
divorced when uh I remember him
saying there's nothing in the world that
makes me happy
anymore and I remember that's a daming
indictment of what of life isn't it it
was and I thought that's not the world's
problem that's yours and we can work on
that but if you are not willing to see
that is not cool to think nothing is
cool then you will never love anything
again including me and thus I cannot
love you and so
um I find that that spark of obsession
doesn't even have to be greatness but
obsession is so contagious uh that it's
like a little bit of oxygen in a Vegas
casino it makes you want to stay up all
night yeah you know anybody that loves
anything is cool the guys on the side of
the road watching Colin McCrae go past
at 120 M hour it's a flash of this one
person that they know about like I went
to uh Cameron Haynes took me to the bow
rack in Eugene Oregon and he tuned up
this bow i' never shot a bow before
since I was like 13 on a holiday doing
like some lame kids club thing and uh
I'm there with the dude that owns the
shop family run shop since the god of
decades and decades and decades and you
know you can tell that it's a well-worn
in shop because there's loads of stuff
that's only there because it's been
accumulated there like it's not precise
it's not neat it's accumul stuff it's
the opposite of an Apple store right
there's like someone brought that cap in
seven years ago and you haven't moved it
yet and it's just been on this window
sill for ages or whatever it's that that
but everywhere and there's all of the
bows and all of the arrows and all of
the different types of arrowe heads and
and all this stuff anyway he's tuning me
up on this bow tuning me up on this bow
tuning me up making sure that
everything's right dials it in he's like
oh that's cool and then I go over to the
kind of like a workman's desk there an
entire workman's area I don't whe you've
ever seen bones bows getting tuned up
yeah yeah yeah so he's like tuning in
the site and he's making sure and then
he does this special thing with uh a
lighter to just make sure that I think
if you heat the thread it binds a little
bit more tightly and he's like oh this
is a little trick that I learned with
whatever whatever like not supposed to
set shock horror bow 101 don't set the
string on fire but like he found that if
he did it a little bit it like tightened
and locked everything in or some other
bits and pieces I was enthralled cuz I
was just around people that were [__]
in love with what they did they were
fired up they were passionate about
their thing I love as well one other
thing that I really really love seeing
is people that have how do you say very
innocuous Mastery right so uh for
instance one of the things that I have
which no one will ever see when I sit
down at my desk stand at my desk to do
the uh episode remotely I can be
thinking about the episode that I've got
coming up whilst doing vocal warm-ups
but the way that all of the studio comes
together of like Mike's in everything's
checked Master is on uh monitoring is
coming through my ears every like just
bu bum and I've seen it with so many
friends a friend that was a doctor and
went to University for basically a
decade to do three degrees worked at
Black Rock became a doctor became a
surgeon and if he has a pen in his hand
he'll just sit there and he'll do the
most insane pen tricks and he's not even
thinking just cuz for familiarity right
like if I saw you uh prepare in fact I
did see you preparing for a talk or
something like that there'll just be
something that people
do oh here's a perfect example I saw a I
saw a guy um playing guitar on Sixth
Street and he's playing away playing
away playing away and this pick like
like just that it's in the crowd or
something like that and without even
thinking he's just like still singing
away pick goes and he doesn't even think
about it he just keeps on playing with
one hand reaches behind himself
unnecessarily Twirls this pick from the
top knuckle all the way down to the
bottom to catch it off and keep going
because he's just done it a million
times so like uh yeah like very normal
Mastery of stuff and that's kind of the
same as take the person that you're
going to date or employee to a
restaurant to see how they treat the
staff yeah it's what do people do in the
beats in between yeah right it's not the
big per performance because that's
dialed it's what's the way that they put
their jacket on before they walk out of
the dressing room yeah what are the
small winds that compound yeah you know
I was thinking about it I think the the
2.0 level to being a person uh that
finds another high value one is not just
being the one in the stands watching
with that wild enthusiasm but finding
the thing that you can actually play in
the game as opposed to be a Voyer in and
so to your point um even if you're not
the champion bow hunter that Cameron
Haynes is being that person who sells
and tweaks and prepares the bow for the
champion is incredible to watch now
Cameron probably makes quite a bit more
money and perhaps is more physically fit
than this other guy and yet both things
are enthralling the necessary right 100%
you know I watched my father for many
years he's a longtime Hunter and he was
the same he'd get up every single
weekend that he could at 3: in the
morning pack a bunch of stuff in order
to drive three or four hours hike a
couple more hours to try to find an elk
and it was like a joke amongst my mom's
friends like yeah you're going to go
look for a you know another elk for days
on end and then eventually one day shoot
one and uh and I remember when my father
and I became like really close and I was
a young girl with with some cognition
about it we would go hunting together
and now my husband will say that I have
quite good eyes so if there's game
around and we're hunting I'm usually the
one that can spot it first because I
have these reps with my father of
watching mov movement across a landscape
and in the way like an animal has a
different shape that you'll never really
find in nature because there's often
smooth lines on animals and on nature
you find much more Jagged uh as the norm
and so um watching him for so many years
do a thing that made no money whatsoever
but him Master it in a way where he
could spot an elk that nobody else in
the entire like uh group could spot even
when he was trying to show them and he
would have to shoot it and down it
before anybody else knew where it was
was so incredible to me from a young age
and so joyful with no um there's nothing
like he he doesn't post on Instagram you
wouldn't be able to find my father
anywhere he's not a showman and yet he
did this thing to the best that he
possibly could every single time because
he had that Obsession and love for it
and I think that's part of why you know
him and my mother have been together for
so many years and I see the same thing
with with my husband you know when you
find a partner who has that wild
Obsession and pursuit it is contagious
and you know Chris is a a purple belt
and we'll get off a flight and you know
I'll go work because I'm obsessed with
working it's my favorite thing to do and
he will go get in the gym immediately
change his clothes and go off to
Jiu-Jitsu because he wants a pursuit of
a black belt and that is really really
cool to watch and you know a bunch of we
have a bunch of friends we both know who
are famous humans they're not always
attracted to like the other famous
humans in their exact same crowd you
know Joe Rogan is attracted to Cameron
Haynes yes because they both shoot um
but also cuz he's like wow this is a
Pursuit that's just so fascinating and
Joe's also interested in somebody like
you who's just obsessed with human
psychology and Frameworks and so um
maybe the the goal to finding an
incredible partner who's top tier in
some way shape or form is just becoming
top tier obsessed with something
yourself that might be enough what was
your Insight about why you should get
into rooms where your average Tuesday is
your best day oh yeah well uh I think
the easiest way to change behavior is to
get around other people who already have
the behavior you want normalized right
and so I would always joke with my
trainer like is your is your six-pack
contagious like can I just like can it
rub off on me and I remember one day he
was like yes I'm like can we explain how
that works he's like because if you hung
out with me all the time I don't drink
I'm up early I work out every day I work
out really hard if you saw my intensity
level paired with the normal person's
intensity level AKA yours at the gym you
would probably uh up yours and it would
just be natural it's actually why I
think group fitness is so important
especially for women who weren't a lot
of us you know I was an athlete in
college uh I'm sorry in high school I
didn't I wasn't an athlete in college
but a lot of women we didn't have that
intensity ingrained in US you didn't
find women fighting and wrestling with
kids until you know we we won some sort
of outcome that wasn't normalized and so
when it comes to really intense workout
Sports I tend to think women are better
off doing group class classes because
you see a bunch of other competitive
people right next to you and you can
uplevel whereas my husband and maybe you
you know if he's in the gym he's just an
animal he nobody could be in there for
weeks and he would act that way and so
that's why I believe get around other
people who what you want just is their
Tuesday yeah what other advice have you
got from billionaires you spent a good
bit of time around wealthy people what
you know lots and lots of net worth
combined in rooms that you've sat in
front of like what are the biggest
takeaways that you've had yeah um well
sort of a Funny Story uh one of the guys
that uh is a billionaire but also spent
some time with Warren Buffett had a
story about how he went to dinner with
Warren and uh I'm a little bit of a
Warren junkie that would be like the guy
that if I got to meet almost anybody
else don't care about him F Girling hard
yeah maybe I could be his third wife
because I
hear uh anyway so um he goes to dinner
with Warren and uh he's like I have 400
questions for Warren because I'm worth
this and he's worth with this and I'm
all excited so I fly there and I go and
sit down for dinner and he's like I
couldn't ask him a question because he
just kept asking me questions all he did
the whole time was pick my brain on what
I thought here what I thought there and
he's like I didn't even realize that
until I left that he had basically
gotten all this information from me and
I had gotten nothing from yeah and he's
like and so he's met a couple other
people that know him too and he's like
the the smartest richest people I know
ask the most questions and try to prove
their intelligence the least because
they know that the ones who collect the
most knowledge have the biggest unfair
advantage and so I found that almost
across the
board that's
interesting what about the there's a lot
of talk about um ethics or lack thereof
in the billionaire class yeah what's
been your experience of
that obviously we have real knowledge
that there are billionaires that have
done horrible things and we've seen that
in the news of of late I do imagine a
bit like the science fiction movies
where once you have a certain level of
money it all becomes a power game and
you lose a sense of reality for what is
actually good bad or otherwise because
you have an ability to actually control
your entire environment and bend it to
your will and the more money you have
the more you can bend your environment
to your will it's just true um one
thing's interesting we have a friend of
ours that runs a family office and was a
of staff for two billionaires and uh and
I remember last time we saw him like
what's going on with you what are we
doing we're explaining what we're
building and you know what our goals
were and kind of what our companies were
worth and he was like I wish you not $1
more than $299 million and I was like
that is such a weird number arbitary
yeah like why 299 and he's like I've run
a family office for multiple
billionaires and I see right about that
amount is when they start losing touch
with reality and when you lose touch
with reality you don't feel like you're
a part of society and when you don't
feel like a part of society you start to
become unhappy and you start to have
really negative decision making and I
thought that was really interesting now
I'm willing to try to be worth over 299
million we can see what it works uh like
for me but I thought that was really
really intriguing Kevin Kelly's got this
piece of advice you must try as hard as
you can under no circumstances to become
a billionaire yeah like his that's
that's his I like Kevin Kelly Kevin
Kevin's I really really enjoyed my
conversation that I had with him I love
his thousand true fans I think that's
true but one thing I would say to get
back to ethics and morals of
billionaires just for one second I have
found that the more people have and have
created the nicer and more giving they
are it's actually those who haven't
created a ton who are still living in
scarcity that are gnarly humans and so
what I find interesting is maybe there's
some level where that changes there's a
goldilock Zone in the middle perhaps and
then can shoot it I mean I told you
today the reason I've got this mark on
my arm here is I had Co last week and it
butt [__] me uh and I was whining to
Rogan the other day about the fact that
I did it and then his nurse showed up at
my house today with an IV bag filled
with
unpronouncable NAD vitamin B phosphate
or some other [__] uh and she sat
there for 2 hours while this thing
slowly went into my body and I was like
oh yeah I feel I feel really good and uh
that was you know a very nice gesture
from someone who didn't need to help not
and and I find that's really really
normal you know I actually asked uh one
of my my friends who's more private as a
billionaire about it and uh and you know
I think a lot of it is learned behavior
right after a while you realize that to
give to people who are givers in return
just multiplies back to you and oddly
the most selfish thing that you can do
somehow somehow and so and then you
learn that it benefits you and then you
get ingrained into your your action um
which I find to be the same thing like
it brings me an obscene amount of joy to
be able to help people except there's a
little twinge if they don't appreciate
it over the long term or if I don't feel
them giving or paying it forward and so
um you know the other thing I guess with
billionaires is they just think
different and everybody at varying
levels of income I mean haven't you felt
that like your first when you first made
your first 30k you're like I'm so rich
I'm not sure what I'm going to buy then
you make a 100K you're like I feel
pretty good I'm like doing pretty well
then you make 250k you're like this is
pretty good I think around 500k uh is
where the the real happiness to increase
past that tapers um and then about you
know a million 10 million there's not
that much difference between the two and
so as you get worth more and more the
only thing that really changes is that
your worldview is so much bigger and so
instead of spending a bunch of time on
$1,000 problems or $100,000 problems you
just naturally gravitate to problems
that will hit the level that you're at
and so it's a huge unlock to be around
more people who have more in fact there
was a great study you would love this
I'll I'll find it so I can send it to
you afterwards but basically showing
that kids in a excuse me if this is
incorrect Minneapolis neighborhood let's
say so same socio demographics of both
groupings of kids but in one segment in
a neighborhood where uh there were only
people of that socio demographic so lots
of people that make below $660,000 a
year and then one segment where they had
a lot of uh interaction between those
with wealth and those without wealth now
the kids grow up in the same types of
environments their parents make the same
amount of monies but this group
interacts with more rich people this
group interacts with less rich people
this group on average makes 33% more
over their lifetime which is astounding
all else being equal if you are around
people that make more money you have the
ability I think to see what options
really are and so I think getting in
rooms with people with big dollar
amounts is actually really really
important you had a contrarian idea
about whether or not you need to sleep
on your couch in order to be successful
what was that yeah Alex and I disagree
on this one because he definitely did uh
I think technically the gym floor for
him yeah he he dreamed of a couch yeah
and other friend Andy fella is the same
you know he has the best culture that
I've ever seen is Andy fella he he his
company first form is is incredible to
me um but he has this huge flag in his
warehouse and the flag was
representative of the exact size of his
very first store that they opened that
they almost lost and went bankrupt on
and the uh in the corner is a
representative of the place that he used
to sleep on the floor on this huge flag
that's located in in their warehouse
house and so he also slept on the floor
to become successful and I commend the
[__] out of people who have had those
sleepless nights without mattresses I
think there are few humans that can
actually persevere through that I think
it breaks a lot of people on the same
vein I think we don't have to have this
hustle porn culture where we think that
is what you have to be willing to do and
in fact what if we gave people the
allotment and the allowance that you
could stay in your relatively
comfortable 9 to5 and build up a
business simultaneously or because I'm
biased buy a business simultaneously and
go from your relatively comfortable 9
to-5 to a slightly harder but more
lucrative XYZ whether it's a side hustle
a startup or a business it's not going
to be easy but I do not think you have
to sleep on Floors to get success and
the reason I say that is because I worry
about people taking a massive amount of
risk um you know studies show if you're
if you're bankrupt once it's incredibly
hard for you to reach Financial Freedom
again you want to almost avoid
bankruptcy at all costs most people
never recover from it and so if we know
that to be true do we play to the edges
to the excellent humans like Andy and
Alex and tell everybody to be like them
look at the size of those [__] calves
look at the size of Andy's guns most
people are never going to be those two
people and so we should allow them the
ability to have massive success without
the massive risk and that's sort of my
nuanced point there that's interesting
you you don't hear it's kind of
survivorship
right that you just exact right you just
don't hear about how many people slept
on the gym floor and then ended up
having to sleep outside on the floor
right you know how many people end up
going bankrupt end up going into
insolvency or Administration for their
business yeah I uh did you ever have to
sleep on a floor no I didn't have to do
it I mean the worst that I ever got I
haven't told this story before the worst
that I ever got was my placement Year
from University and I was living in
Scotland so we ran
a we had the franchise when I was 19 I
picked up my first franchise for uh
night club Bar Crawl called Carnage and
this was you wore a T-shirt and on the
T-shirt were the list of bars that you
were going to go through and there were
tasks on the back uh like pulled a pig
uh down three drinks did a blah this is
a different era when we could you could
do this sort of stuff um and we would it
was a like to print money I it's a liced
to print like very normal amounts of
money but it was it was very reliable in
terms of how it's sold out and the goal
was to expand this into new cities so we
put it in Newcastle me and my business
partner dominate um and were very very
good at this then I was from Middlesboro
Town 50 miles away I knew that that was
a [__] hole I thought that that would
work well sure enough it did it's full
of Larry degenerates that that loved it
and we had a great time it was really
fun our placement your was coming up
from University from my business degree
and the owner of the franchise big dog
like look why don't you come and work
for me you guys are already more Fed Up
about work than you are about your
business degrees so why not just like go
full-time in the thing that you're
almost full-time and with this part-time
degree on the side and then go back to
UNI once you're done we like yeah yeah
that works so we move up to Edinburgh we
move into this apartment and we're in
Edinburgh for all of the summer I'm
going to the University of Edinburgh gym
I'm walking down uh the
Royal Mile in Edinburgh every single day
getting annoyed by French children who
are off to the Edinburgh Fringe Festival
um and we're driving around Scotland we
had Sterling Dundee Glasgow and
Edinburgh as four cities Plus Newcastle
and Middlesboro so it's like a pretty
big net you know from Dundee down to
Newcastle is probably 300 350 miles
maybe it's a good distance anyway so
we're doing this little Loop and we're
going to different places and dropping
off flyers and making sure that the
guest list staff and the selling Stu all
of these things are occurring and the
problem with events is that you only get
paid once they've happened and we were
building up to this big big big chunk of
events but we had no income coming in in
the interim and I needed to keep on
getting our boss to send me money to be
later deducted from our cut so that I
could have petrol to drive to the places
and there was a period where it was like
okay I I actually don't have money to
eat here and I had a guy that came and
stayed with me who was going to help and
he come from a little bit more of a uh
like nasty background than mine he was
like dude I'll just go and steal some
food from the store and I'm like bro if
I descend to the point where I have to
steal [__] food like the I the guy
that owns the company earns easily
enough money I can just get him to wire
us some cash but that was that was a
period I remember I once went to go and
see Underoath like a metal band I went
to go and see them I went from Edinburgh
to Glasgow to go and see Underoath play
and it was I knew that by doing that I
couldn't drive my car like it was the
amount of fuel I had to get there and
come back and I was like supposed to
drive to work or whatever the next day
and I was like eat [__] I'm going to go
watch this band so I drove there on my
own watched the band drove back on my
own got home and I was like okay I've
got like 15 miles of fuel in the tank
and that was it but it wasn't destitute
that was a very short space of time uh
and largely you know I I straddled you
know three or four different IND Ries am
I going to be a DJ am I going to go
full-time with commercial modeling am I
going to go continue to build the
nightlife business then the podcast
comes along and it just permitted me to
kind of weather the storm very nicely
and I realized I didn't want to do late
night stuff being a DJ is is fun from
the outside but kind of painful from the
inside the modeling stuff was
depreciating asset as you said earlier
on uh I was like okay podcast there it
is but yeah by tinkering around it gave
me the options I remember when when we
first met I didn't know your background
or who you were and so I was Googling
you because I have two Brits on my team
you remember those two and one of them's
a crazy kid and they were so excited to
meet you and I was like who is this guy
like what is you know Chris what what's
his deal and uh and so I was Googling
you and like the first pictures come up
and they're like like you shirtless you
know like this from your which I didn't
even know what love Island was um
sheltered sheltered life you've beening
apparently um and I remember sort of
laughing because I heard you speak and I
was like well it's not the same guy
because we've got this really well
spoken gent who has like ABS all over
the Internet what's going on here um and
then uh and then like seeing your
background I think it's really
interesting to see the cobbled together
history that equates to something rather
Frankenstein's monster yeah but that's
how most people I mean I was I thought
that you went to University and you knew
what you wanted and then you went to
your first job and then you climbed the
ladder and then you continued up the
corporate sphere and I'm probably one of
the very very few corporate people I
mean I was corporate for 12 years at Big
financial institutions and and finally
had the balls but didn't have it before
to step out and and do things on my own
that's really rare uh actually in
entrepreneurship and so I'm trying to
speak to anybody in your audience who is
in that corporate position that they
really hate that right now you're
sitting there thinking I am watching
this clock tick from 452 to 459 and it
feels like it's 12 years of my life and
I'm actively sitting here thinking I
want to be closer to death just so that
I can get up from this job and I want to
reach that person and say you don't have
to have a wild origin story in order to
be really successful it's really
wonderful if you have the David goggin
incredible background where you have
overcome such Strife to achieve success
but it is actually not necessary and you
can create just as much of a hero story
for yourself having come from monotony
as you can having come from travesty and
most humans today aren't getting that
story because we want to idealize which
is actually great for the big big
victims out there if you've had huge
difficulty it's actually a superpower
you just don't realize it yet but you
don't need it you can still be wildly
successful and interesting by just
applying it but maybe the only thing I
would ask your opinion on you know
there's another guy that we know who has
a podcast and I remember he was asking
me like how to grow this how do I grow
this podcast you know how do I get it
bigger and and my I kind of thought
about it for a second I was like there's
a bunch of itics I could tell you right
now but I think the most important
tactic would be go and do something
really interesting instead of just
trying to go interview a bunch of people
who are interesting and use their clout
to grow your podcast go do something
wild go do something interesting
yourself build something yourself create
some stories and then enter the chamat
arena um and I think a lot of people
these days are missing that and that's
why there's push back to gurus on social
media and that's why most podcasts only
last seven episodes is because because
they think to do the thing they just
mimic the big interviewing of humans but
there's a reason why you get really
interesting podcast guest it's because
you are uniquely interesting too it's
because you have crazy pictures of ABS
on the internet you're on a reality TV
show you've been in the grind of
building businesses you also have this
weird sort of modern-day stoicism
philosopher aspect and all of that
together is packaged a human that is
unique Chris Williamson and so how can
you allow yourself a little Adventure
that actually equals your success but it
doesn't have to be tragedy I don't think
no I don't think so either I you are
right trying to growth hack being in
interesting not not cool is rough and
you're right as well I think it's the
reason why there is skepticism around
gurus on the internet because it it
seems like the story is fragile and if I
hit it with a strong enough Hammer it'll
shatter and the hope is almost in some
regards that I can shatter it you know
um this is why people I think are going
after Logan Paul's relationship amongst
a whole host of other reasons one of
them being
that there's a skepticism around both
his and his partner's Fidelity Logan
Paul's kind of portrayed as the king of
the Bros and his mes has got a history
as well and all right like let's keep
hitting this thing I'm pretty sure that
there's nothing there let's keep hitting
it going to keep hitting it and then
maybe working working on the other side
there's podcasters who've got huge huge
platforms online and there's as many
haters as there are like and critics and
Skeptics and stuff and all that they do
is spend their time trying to find holes
and I think a big chunk of that is that
they think maybe maybe there is
something hollow inside of that and if I
keep whacking it enough then it it won't
work it'll break so yeah I think we
should be cautious of portraying like an
infallible front yeah one of the ways
that you can kind of protect yourself
quite nicely against that just as a
normal person you know nobody likes
someone who doesn't seem to have any
vulnerabilities doesn't seem to have any
problems yeah exactly
like we bond with people over their
flaws as much as we Bond bond with them
over their successes but the flaws
humanize them if you've got someone and
you're like oh this guy a girl doesn't
seem to struggle with anything so what
what am I going to bond with you over
like what are you are you just a [__]
are you an equation who are you uh and
you
can by wearing your weaknesses on your
sleeve not running with a victim
mentality and not exposing them
unnecessarily but you know if someone
ask today the this people pleaser thing
is like a revelation I've learned within
literally the last two weeks right so
I'm like all right I guess I'm part of
the people pleaser club and this is kind
of a new thing for me to realize and
learn about myself and now I don't know
like there's other people out there that
are people Pleasers and they think [__]
like that's maybe that's me too so yeah
giving that gift of like self-insight I
think is it's true well I also I think
people really don't like seeing Perfect
People for whatever reason I think
that's a flaw we should work on that we
should be thrilled if somebody seems to
have all the things together that to me
I'd rather air on the side of optimism
that somebody else could have those
things and that means maybe I could too
you know maybe I don't have everything
right now but maybe I could if this
other human does but I think for
instance you know there's a reason that
characters are created when people have
personas and those characters are very
thoughtfully you know made I I always
like talking about or thinking about the
rock because I think he seems like a
good guy and I also think he's much more
crafted than people give him credit for
agree I think so too the way he dresses
you know so as to not look too
intimidating and also sort of like the
people's champ which is what he calls
himself even the way he humanizes what
he talks about calling himself the
people's champ right um I think these
these characters are created because we
realize that nobody likes a glass house
we want to see if we can break it and
for for I'm a little embarrassed because
I couldn't stop watching the whole Dylan
danis Logan Paul thing on Twitter I mean
I was like when some my husband cuz he's
a Jiu-Jitsu guy you know could watch the
fights and whatever so when some of his
like degenerate friends sent me sort of
the stuff they were doing back and forth
you know I fell in I'm like oh my god
did she really say that what happened
compelling oh very great content premium
content and yet as I was watching it all
I'm like at the end of this I have a
feeling they're both kind of losing
correct and I think they both they took
it like a little too far they could have
actually stopped at some point and um
and then it just gets gnarly and and at
the core of it I don't think think
humans are as bad as we make them out to
be I think we like a little drama we
want to tear people down slightly but it
gets too far and we go ah this is gross
I'm out of here by and large and I think
that's what happened with both of them
you know and um and yet like for me I'm
both sides I just find it so funny like
who cares who cares what these two
humans that none of us know are doing on
the internet and why do we get so
fixated on somebody else's life and
projecting what we think should be right
on them one of the things that you don't
see and you can't do it if you're about
to punch somebody else in the face
because it makes you seem like a coward
it makes you seem like you have limits
and the whole game of this is I have no
limits right that's fundamentally I
think what's happening I'm prepared to
go further than you I'm prepared to be
more ruthless than you this is this
great story of Tyson Fury and I think it
was Vladimir Klitschko and him this is
way before they were going to fight
maybe even years before they were going
to fight and they were both in a sauna
together and Tyson Fury just silently
made a promise to himself he's like I'm
dying or he's leaving first I'm going to
die or he's going and they're in there
for like 30 minutes 40 minutes 50
minutes forever however long it is
Klitschko gets up and goes and he's like
I knew I'd beat him I knew I'd beat him
as soon as that had happened and oh yeah
interesting yeah yeah yeah so so who do
you think wins the Logan Paul Dyan danis
really important question for this in
terms of the actual fight yeah and does
it matter anymore
does it matter anymore well I mean
they've both lost and we've all won so
far uh I really don't know Dylan danis
has been fighting for a long time I've
seen some footage of him hitting pads it
doesn't look good Logan Paul looks great
at the moment physical condition is
fantastic uh and he looks good hitting
pads too but he's also I think never won
a fight I don't think he he's ever
actually won uh and Dylan definitely
does seem quite calm uh let's
say uh Dylan by decision wow goes the
goes the distance both but it's a ugly
fight it's both very bumbling nobody
looks particularly slick uh I would say
Logan by knockout or Dylan by decision I
don't think Dylan's going to knock Logan
out because of the size difference um
but one of the other things that you see
right the talking about who's going to
go further and that story of Klitschko
and uh Tyson
Fury there is
a an amount of how far you
go that actually becomes a counter
signal after a while and what it teaches
the world is oh you you kind of don't
have any morals there's nothing left
there's no sacred ground left and this
can be done from the receiver as well as
the accuser right and this is what I
meant on Twitter you never see anybody
on Twitter which is crazy because of how
many insults get thrown around on
Twitter and DMS and sub tweets and all
that [__] you never see anyone on
Twitter say reply and go yo that's out
of order and you don't get to [__]
say that don't talk to me like that no
one has ever replied with that on
Twitter but you do that in person
someone like you and your partner and
your partner actually decides to bring
up that thing that they know hurts you
and you they promised that they wouldn't
or it's just beyond the payLo whatever
and you go yo you don't get to talk
about that okay yeah like no one does
that on twit it's always a a sardonic
satirical reworking of what they
actually said or it's a screenshot of
what their wife did the other day or
what it's some [__] [__] like
what would have been an interesting
strategy and again it doesn't work quite
so well because it's like oh you're
bowing out this is like uh complicity
and and cowardice and and weakness or
whatever but what would have been an
interesting strategy for Logan at least
to have done in this particular exchange
would have been to gone you're a piece
of [__] you don't get to talk about
someone's fiance that way I'll see the
[__] fight yeah age and you go oh
that's [__] interesting right and it
makes you look like the bigger man
problem being all of these tweets are
like Logan is financially invested in
like he's very very incentivized in
ticking this over uh but yeah had you
have not had that on the other side had
there have just been some you know like
meaningless beef W with no face punching
at the end of it I would been interested
to
see if he could have played it in a more
noble way I agree yeah I also thought
about it from the woman's perspective of
[__] rough is mostly what I think
rough and also what would you want your
man to do if that was you in that
situation very rough for them as as a
couple I think on either side I cannot
imagine I actually asked my husband I
was like what if that was me he was like
oh God you know just like a visceral
reaction and we're very close and
married for a long time but that is like
a primal Instinct I think in men that we
just have to be honest about so that had
to make for fun conversation between the
two of them I don't wish anything on
that and on the other side you know
there's part of me that I think would
have said [__] the purse like why why
are we continuing to engage with a
person that's done this and despite it
making you a ton of money you know is it
worth it because her reputation has been
severely beaten up and she'll have to
come up with something really creative
to turn that around if she cares yeah
the Rebrand of Nina is going to be an
interesting
one I don't know I mean we we pray at
the altar
of status and Prestige and money and we
will do an awful lot to kind of get
there and it's part of that brand as
well it's part of that like turbo alpha
male
machismo nothing can [__] with me dude
I'm
untouchable uh but again you know if if
I think he'd said something like uh like
she doesn't care about you uh this isn't
going to be a big deal uh she thinks
that you're like scum and and that
you're despicable but like she doesn't
care about you I'm like again I maybe
that's the case maybe the the whole
relationship is like that but if you'd
said like she's really been [__] hurt
by this like You' really hurt her like
that's a that's a headline like Dylan
danis is emotionally abusive to a that
he's never spoken to 100% especially
some of the stuff just pictures of her
with men I'm like God I mean [__]
funny though well that is the problem I
was on all of my my you know gents
friends text messages and just don't
pretend that you weren't following it
yourself oh I I I I admitted it I was I
was admittingly embarrassingly following
it for a period but then I had to turn
it off because it got I thought it would
Peter out well remember what I said
content diet right amydala the fast food
for the all over again like what does it
make you here's another good way right
when you watch your current content feed
or Creator not necessarily of choice but
like the algorithm's creator of choice
that it's feeding you how do you feel I
call it post content Clarity um how do
you feel the opposite it's like fog well
it's just like are you do you want to
ring your mom and tell her that you miss
her do you want to go outside and go for
a nice walk and be calm and look at the
sky or do you feel like the world's out
to get you and everything's pointless
and it's zero some Doggy Dog scarcity
World mentality and when I think about
some of the most popular channels and
how they make me feel they make me
feel rubbish afterward I don't I don't
like the person that I am and I almost
need to like acutely rehabilitate myself
back into being the person I am after
watching this content well especially
something like that you know I was I was
talking to one of my friends and
immediately you know what I think about
I imagine it like if my attention span
or if my attention and focus is an
apartment let's say I consider a
penthouse like this space in here is
actually quite nice and it's very
expensive and everything that I allow
into that apartment is me Airbnb in it
out I'm renting my mind out to these
people and I have just given these two
dudes you know this apartment for a week
free you know they've gotten this
Penthouse level attention which has some
cost and it's not been a net benefit to
me so I've rented it out to them for
nothing and
uh and every time I rephrase it that way
I'm like oh yeah I would I wouldn't do
that I wouldn't allow these type of
people to steal my attention for a week
if my attention was an actual house in
which I lived and by the way my brain
your brain is much more valuable than
some Airbnb Penthouse you could have and
so um my mind always goes back to the
numerical calculus of what is it costing
you so you can feel it in your energy
you can certainly feel it in in your
output which I guess could be monetarily
driven but yeah at the end of it I was
just thinking God these two OTS are
living rentree in my mind for much too
long it's totally my fault big hidden
metric again uh I love contrarian
thinking I love your uh newsletter where
should people go if they want to sign up
to that thank you it's contrarian
thinking. Co fantastic and where else
should they go if they want to follow
the things that you do on all the
socials uh we do a lot on YouTube we do
a lot lot on Instagram and uh yeah I
hope they tell me if they end up uh
buying a business which is what we talk
about the most hell yeah I appreciate
you thank you for having me if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
subscribe